I would like to tell you about the most
powerful woman you've never heard of
this is septima Clark remember her name
septima Clark dr. King called her the
architect of the civil rights movement
because she created something called
citizenship schools and in those schools
she taught ordinary women the practical
skills to go back into their communities
and teach people to read because if they
could read they could vote while these
women took those organizing skills and
they became some of the most legendary
civil rights activists this country has
ever seen
women like Diane Nash you may know her
she orchestrated the entire walk from
Selma to Montgomery she was the
co-founder of the Student Nonviolent
Coordinating Committee and they
integrated lunch counters and they
created the Freedom Rides or you may
remember fannie lou hamer who sat on the
floor of the Democratic National
Convention and talked about being beaten
in jail cells as she registered people
to vote in Mississippi and her most
famous student Rosa Parks she said
septima Clark was the one who taught her
the peaceful act of resistance and when
she sat down she inspired a nation to
stand these were just three of her
10,000 students these women stood on the
front lines of change and by doing so
they taught people to read in her
citizenship school model and empowered
700,000 new voters and that's not it she
created a new culture of social activism
Pete Seeger said it was septima Clark
who changed the lyrics to the old gospel
song and made the anthem we all know we
shall overcome now many of you may know
us we are the cofounders of girltrek the
largest Health Organization for black
women in America our mission is simple
ask black women 80% of whom are over a
healthy body weight to walk outside of
their front door every day to estab
publish a life-saving habit of walking
in doing so ignite a radical movement in
which black women reverse the
devastating impacts of chronic disease
reclaim the streets of their
neighborhoods create a new culture of
health for their families and stand on
the front lines for justice today all
across America more than a hundred
thousand black women are wearing this
girl trek blue shirt as they move
through their communities a heroic force
we walk in the footsteps of septima
Clark she gave us a blueprint for change
making one to have a bold idea bigger
than anyone is comfortable with to to
root down in the cultural traditions of
your community and lean heavily on what
has come before two three name it that
one thing that everyone is willing to
work hard for a ridiculously simple goal
that doesn't just benefit the individual
but the village around them until lastly
never ask permission to save your own
life it is our fundamental right as
human beings to solve our own problems
so to the women all out there gathered
in your living rooms rooting for us
acting crazy on social media right now
we see you we see you every day we love
you you are not alone and our bigger
work starts now
you got us onto this stage your
leadership auditing blighted streets in
Detroit working with hospitals and
health care systems in Harlem praying
over the streets of Sacramento Charlotte
Brooklyn Flint and every community that
has seen trauma changing traffic
patterns making your streets safer and
most importantly standing as role models
and it all started with your commitment
to start walking your agreement to
organize your friends and family and
your beliefs and our
broader mission it's important to me
that everyone in this room understands
exactly how change-making works and
girltrek
one well-trained organizer has the power
to change the behavior of 100 of her
friends we know that is true because the
100,000 women blowing up social media
right now have already inspired over
100,000 women to walk but that is not
nearly enough and so our goal is to
create critical mass and in order to do
that we have an audacious plan to scale
our intervention a thousand organizers
is not enough girltrek is going to
create the next citizenship school and
in doing so we will train 10,000
frontline health activists and deploy
them into the highest feed communities
in America because when we do we will
disrupt disease we will create a new
culture of help and what we will do was
create a support system for 1 million
black women to walk to save their own
lives
and our training is unparalleled I just
want you to imagine it's like a revival
tent like festival not like unlike the
civil rights movement teach-ins
and we're going to go all across the
country it is the biggest announcement
this week Vanessa and I and a team of
masterful teachers all to culminate next
year on sacred ground in Selma Alabama
to create a new annual tradition that we
are calling Summer of Soma summer of
Selma will be an annual pilgrimage that
will include a walk 54 miles the sacred
route from Selma to Montgomery it will
also include rigorous training picture
it as women come to learn organizing and
recruitment strategies to study Exercise
Science to take nutrition classes to
learn storytelling to become certified
as outdoor trip leaders and community
advocates this is going to be
unprecedented it's going to be a moment
in time like a cultural institution and
in fact it's gonna be the Woodstock a
black girl healing
in the need it's more urgent than ever
we are losing our community's greatest
resource black women are dying in plain
sight and not only is no one talking
about it but we refuse to acknowledge
that the source of this crisis is rooted
in the same injustice that first
propelled the civil rights movement on
December 30th of 2017 erica garner the
daughter of Eric garner a black man who
died on the streets of New York from a
police chokehold passed away of a heart
attack erica was just 27 years old the
mother of two children she would be one
of a hundred and thirty seven black
women that date more than 50,000 in the
last year two died from a heart-related
issue many of their hearts broken from
trauma the impacts of stress on black
women who send their children and
spouses out the door each day unsure if
they will come home alive who work jobs
where they are paid sixty three cent to
every dollar paid to white men who live
in communities with crumbling
infrastructure with no access to fresh
fruits or vegetables with little to no
walkable or green spaces the impact of
this inequality is killing black women
at higher and faster rates than any
other group in the country but that is
about to change it has to so let me tell
you a story about three weeks ago many
of you may have watched Vanessa and I in
a team of 10 women walked 100 miles on
the actual Underground Railroad we did
it in five days five long and beautiful
days and the world watched three million
people watched
live stream some of you in here the
influencer shared the story urban radio
blasted it across the country even the E
News Channel interrupted a story about
the Kardashians which you asked as we
asked us is just a little bit of justice
to report that girltrek had made it
safely on our hundred mile journey
people were rooting for us and they were
rooting for us because in this time of
confusion and contention this journey
allowed us all to reflect on what it
meant to be American we saw America up
close and personal as we walked we
walked through historic towns through
dense forests past former plantations
and one day we walked into a gas station
that was also a cafe and it was filled
with men they were wearing camo and had
hunting supplies and out front were all
of their trucks and one had a
confederate flag and so we we left the
establishment and as we're walking along
this narrow strip of road a few of the
trucks reared by us so close and out of
their tailpipe was the specter of mob
violence it was unnerving but then it
happened right on the border of Maryland
and Delaware we saw a man standing by
his truck the tailgate was down he had
on a brown jacket he was standing there
awkwardly the first two girls in our
group Jule and Sandra they walked by
because he looked suspicious with the
bigger group we stopped to give him a
chance and he walked up to us and he
said hi my name is Jake green I heard
you on Christian radio this morning and
God told me to bring you supplies
he brought us water he brought us
granola and he brought us tissue and we
needed tissue because we had just walked
through a nor'easter it was 29 degrees
it was fleeting on our face our sneakers
and our socks were frozen and and wet
and frozen again we needed that tissue
more than he could have possibly
understood so on that day in that moment
Jake green renewed my faith and God for
sure but he renewed my faith in humanity
we have a choice to make in America we
can fall further into the darkness of
discord or not and I am here to tell you
that the women of girltrek are walking
through the streets with a light that
cannot be extinguished
they are also walking through the
streets with a mission as clear and as
powerful as the women who marched in
Montgomery that disease stops here that
trauma stops here and with your support
and in our ancestors footsteps these
10,000 newly trained activists will
launch the largest health revolution
this country has ever seen
and they will return to their
communities and model the best of human
flourishing and we we will all celebrate
because like Jake Greene understood our
fates are intertwined septima Clark once
said the air has finally gotten to a
place where we can breathe it together
and yet the haunting last words of Eric
garner where I can't breathe and his
daughter Erica died at 27 years old
still seeking justice so we were gonna
keep doing Septimus work until her words
become reality
until black women are no longer dying
until we can all breathe the air
together
[Applause]
[Music]